all right guys bang-bang
I've got miss polenta here with me we're
going to try to do this for about an
hour or so I'm going to start off going
over the economy real quick kind of what
happened over the past week or so and
then Polina is here to make sure that
actually intelligent things are said so
if you can before I forget subscribe to
the channel and click the like button
I keep getting hammered over the head
that's what you have to do so more
people can see this let's jump into the
economy so it's pretty obvious I think
one that the economic data we're seeing
or how the economic reality is much much
worse than what we're seeing in the
stock market for example but there's
been this dislocation between stock
prices and economic reality so in q1 GDP
went down 4.8% negative GDP there we're
also seeing unemployment kind of just
falling off a cliff right I mean
literally we've seen 30 million plus
Americans file for unemployment in the
last six weeks a lot of people those
thirty million people is the official
number so the unofficial number is much
higher than that you can think about
this from the perspective of freelancers
gig economy workers self-employed most
of those people are not getting access
to unemployment claims and then on top
of that there's still people having
trouble getting the unemployment so -
over 30 million Americans somewhere
between 16 to 20 percent depending on
what the official number actually is
unemployment in the United States and go
back to the Great Depression the Great
Depression started out with 3.1 percent
unemployment we had 3.5 percent earlier
this year at the end of February we went
from three point one percent the Great
Depression in 1929 up to over 20 percent
it took three years to get there but
within three years we were over 20
percent it took us six weeks six weeks
which is gonna be pretty pretty bad
obviously
and so GDP is down unemployment is
skyrocketing
when you look kind of through that the
government has stepped in and they're
trying to provide relief and so the
Paycheck protection program are PPP
loans they basically said at first
there's gonna be 350 billion dollars for
the loans available for small businesses
it's been a complete [ __ ] show to be
completely honest we've seen everything
from 200 plus public companies getting
access to these loans to multi-billion
dollar companies getting access to the
loans and there's a lot of small
businesses that are left hanging right
only 3 to 4 percent of the loans were
actually processed in kind of first wave
the government then approved another 310
billion dollars of PPP loans but my
guess is that less than 15% of all loan
applications have actually been
processed successfully and so that means
that there's a lot of small businesses
that are struggling that then brings us
to kind of the question of the of the
moment if you will which is the health
crisis is well understood in that there
is a virus it is infecting people it is
killing people but I do think that there
is a big question around should we
reopen economy or not and so various
states are starting to move into that
right now some states are being more
aggressive and opening the economy than
others but really the question is how
fast should we do this is now the right
time and what will be the impact of
opening that economy and I think that we
can spend a lot of time talking through
the various aspects there but that's
kind of the situation at the moment and
so maybe what we can do is if you guys
want leave some questions in leave
questions in the comments here I see you
guys asked complain in a way that you
and will try to do our best to answer as
many of them as we can what do you think
about the opening reopening the economy
so I think that we're headed in that
direction I just spoke with family in
Bulgaria and they're kind of slowly
reopening my aunt told me that as of
today you don't have to wear masks
outside only in indoor areas and
restaurants that have like a little
outdoor area or like a terrace can open
up so this is a really important point
when you're reading on the Internet is a
bunch of stupid
from the people who are taking these
videos of the protests so there's a lot
of people who are out of jobs 30-plus
million Americans they need income in
order to survive and they are out in the
streets protesting saying open up the
economy and I think what we're starting
to realize here is that there's a very
big divergence between the social
pressure what is politically correct to
say which is stay inside save lives that
whole narrative versus the actual
science and to your point what Bulgaria
has figured out many other countries
around the world is that there's very
little evidence that transmission
happens on a frequent basis outdoors
right as long as people aren't sitting
inside houses right most of the
person-to-person transmission is
happening inside of apartments inside of
homes instead of offices and so if
you're outside there's really a much
less need to wear a mask and we should
actually encourage people to go outside
stay away from people but still go
outside because there's less
transmission that occurs there than
inside of the home but what signs did
you read to suggest that well there's
there's a number of studies we can put
them in the comments right but but the
whole point here being that what we are
realizing is that the data that a lot of
the decisions were originally made on is
inaccurate right if you go back and look
at everything from the imperial college
study to even more recent studies there
was concern that the death rate was two
three four percent now scientists this
is part of the process right as you come
up with kind of a base case a worst case
and a best case scenario as that's what
they were doing but the data is now
telling us that the death rate it
indefinitely in the United States is
below one person so it's trending more
towards the best case scenario rather
than the worst case scenario
directionally and therefore it's okay
for us to change our mind when we get
new information so can I ask if I'm a
politician what are the chances I change
my mind based on new information and new
facts if that pisses off my constituency
well this is gets to the crux of the
issue is we have bad leaders across the
aisle both sides of the aisle we are
watching bad leadership and I'll give
you two examples one is it would be
incredibly compelling for somebody to
stand up in front of a camera in front
of an audience
and say we made the right decision at
the time we thought that this could be
incredibly bad and kill a lot of people
we then overreacted intentionally and
told everyone to get in their homes and
shelter in place that was the right
decision because it was the absolute we
prepared for the worst
or we just used the information we had
at the time which wasn't very robust we
now have more information and we don't
need to overreact as much and therefore
we are going to put a plan in place to
reopen the economy in a safe and
intelligent way which includes two major
components one we're going to reopen the
economy if you would like to go back
voluntarily you are welcome to do that
we would like you to wear a mask we
would like you to socially distance we
would like you to wash her hands right
all of these different components that
we know are really important the second
piece is we are still going to put into
place things that will protect people so
there's two main constituents of people
one there's a lot of people who aren't
comfortable going back to work they
aren't comfortable going back we will
legally protect you so if you don't want
to go back to your job we will make sure
that they can't fire you because of this
they can because there's a lot of people
who are in need of jobs right now in
telling a small business owner hey you
need to keep this person's position
because they're not you don't feel safe
going back to work instead of hiring
somebody else like what do you do so
we'll get to that in one second the
second group of people is the old right
the elderly the sick or those with
pre-existing conditions we should
shelter them in place right we should do
everything to protect them and the
people who are not comfortable going
back to work basically what you then say
is exactly what you're already doing
most of those people have lost their
jobs right and so what they're faced
with whether we like it or not is do I
go make a living or do I actually and so
I think that we just have to be very
intelligent how we reopen the economy
and we have to get people back to work
now a key component of this is it would
require a large portion of politicians
to have the courage to stand up and say
hey we did what was right at the time
we've gotten new information we are now
changing our mind that's not what's
going on the second thing that's very
telling is I am shocked that we have not
seen a state governor step up and say I
have told the small-business owners and
the employees that work in my state that
they need to give up their income they
need to give up their livelihood I've
shut down their businesses for public
health reasons I am shocked we haven't
seen a governor say I will go I will
forgo my income until we get people back
to work and it's the whole idea of a
leader should never ask somebody to do
something but they're unwilling to do
themselves and it just feels like
there's just this vacuum of leadership
across local state federal level and
denials because these are the
conversations we have on Saturday nights
yesterday we were talking about the
difference between power and leadership
and I thought you brought up with a
point that the people we thought were
powerful in this time of crisis we find
are not as powerful and in fact are not
good leaders so in terms of crisis you
don't want power you seek leadership of
course and also you know one of the
things that we talked about last night
that that was really telling is a lot of
power is derived by people's position
and what that basically means is if I am
the governor of a state I have power
because of my position but that is
authoritative leadership right meaning
that I literally i outrank you I'm in
charge you work for me you do as I said
yeah
when those people leave office they lose
all of the Power
right the powers derive from the
position instead what we need is we need
more influential leadership which is
people are inspired to follow that
leader because they actually believe in
what that person is saying yeah and
they're trying to do it just nobody
believes them right this whole idea of
like we have to do this together
whatever yes that was true and we didn't
have information now that the
information is coming out everyone's
looking around and saying wait a second
this is nowhere near as bad as you guys
want and remember the shelter in place
was put in place because they were
scared of overwhelming the hospitals the
hospitals are not overwhelmed right
remember all of the things they sneered
loosen the restrictions that they will
become overwhelmed again potentially
that's true
but I believe this that is correct we
can double Chile give fact check it
I believe that for every one person that
is labeled a corona virus death right
labeled a corona virus death 500 people
in the United States have loss has lost
their job it's a death hey I get what
you're saying but but now this brings to
the question of is it actually a corona
virus death and this is my biggest
problem right and again vit what I'm
about to say means that this could say
that the situation is better or worse
right it's we don't know if the
situation is better or worse because the
numbers are inaccurate so anybody who
understands data and math would look at
this and say right now in the United
States 60,000 people are being labeled
as a corona virus death here's what goes
into that number people who actually
died from corona virus they're in that
number people who have corona virus
they're infected if they take the test
they're positive and then they die from
something else so if you have a heart
attack but you had corona virus you're a
corona virus - yeah and then it begs the
question of did corona virus accelerate
your pre-existing condition except
absolutely there's just a lot of
elements but that means that there's
questions on the data the third bucket
which is the most egregious part that
goes into that 60,000 number is if you
do not test positive for a corona virus
and you died but they believed that you
had corona virus you get incorporated in
the number as well so right there
we know that there's two buckets of
people who are being included in the
death number that are not actually
testing positive or don't actually die
from corona virus we can't prove it now
on the flip side of that arguing ready
to flip around to be intellectually
honest and say well there's also an
explosion of people who are dying at
home who we don't know right so there's
let's say 2 to 4 to 6 X more people
dying at home and not in the hospital
could those be corona related for sure
and so again it goes back to I'm not
making the argument that were over
county or under coming what I'm arguing
is that the numbers inaccurate and
therefore what we're starting to see is
even with an inaccurate number
it's still way lower than we originally
thought so even if you put all of those
people in to that number that we have
questions as to whether they actually
died from chrono virus or not it's still
low below okay so we get to this after
talking about leadership well because
this is the whole thing right is why is
there not a leader stepping up and
saying the date isn't accurate what's an
example who's an example of a good
leader in this period of time right now
I actually think the best leaders right
now are the leaders at the local level
because the leaders at the local level
are most likely to have that influential
leadership already in place because they
have that emotional connection there
they're spending time with the people
accepting the politicians
well politicians at the local level for
sure are the most likely out of all the
political stack but also what I mean is
the small business owners right the
individuals who are you know I have a
manufacturing company and I used to make
something else but now also we need
masks great I switch my operations and I
start to make masks right I'm providing
value I'm trying to contribute to the
solution what I see a lot of politicians
doing is frankly the exact opposite
which is I'm just gonna sit up here and
I'm going to complain I'm gonna keep
saying this data and I'm gonna keep
counting the table saying how bad it is
my problem with politicians is that it
feels like and I've written about this
before how even when they get new
information they rarely change their
mind and so what they do is they double
down on their original position even if
it's wrong and even if it's bad for the
people so that's what this is me yeah I
wanted to know so alright there's a tons
of questions leave your questions in
here we're gonna start answering one of
the questions I saw back up here was
basically this idea of the Federal
Reserve and do we think that the Federal
Reserve could just sit and print money
forever
the money printer Gober now turned into
is my way of saying it but essentially
what's going on is the thorough reserve
I think it's now over three trillion
dollars that's been printed that
dislocation the stock market I started
off talking about is really kind of the
the stock market is not a representation
of the economy is a representation of
central bank actions although the
economic data is getting worse GDP down
four-and-a-half 4.8% 30 million
Americans unemployed instead what we're
seeing is a stock market rally that's
because
that is stepping in and printing so much
money two schools of thought and I want
to know which one you think is the right
school of thought one the Federal
Reserve is actually doing a good job to
stabilize markets and have asset prices
recover by acting very quickly using the
2008 2009 playbook to print as much
money as possible and although there may
be long-term consequences to their
actions it solves or at least mitigates
some of the short-term risk and issues
that's bucket number one bucket number
two is you are printing trillions of
dollars and you're going to devalue your
currency which will lead to high levels
of inflation later and you shouldn't
make the long-term negative trade-off
for short-term benefit what do you think
is the right answer
Moe is long-term but right now I feel
like people I mean we want to run the
other day and we saw at a food bank the
line was around the block if not longer
um it's very hard to say oh no let the
people suffer now because it'll be good
for our long-term lives so I don't know
I don't like the printing of the money
but I also don't like letting the people
suffer what goes back to incentives also
right remember that if you're a
politician you're not gonna be in office
most likely that's ten years from now so
they're just kind of doing it well what
do you what do you do if 30 million
Americans are unemployed right you try
to solve the problem right now because
even if you can solve for the long-term
problem the short-term problem is I got
30 million people right or however many
people in my state or my city that are
hungry without jobs need help right I
got small businesses that are suffering
cetera and so what I actually think is
going to happen is you're gonna see the
Federal Reserve continue to try to solve
this problem and the number one kind of
question and financier enough you said
to me right now what is the absolute
cross like pinpoint where the market is
being made it is the question of will we
continue in a deflationary environment
meaning that all of this money printing
won't matter because the deflationary
environment will suck up that liquidity
that's what happened in 2008-2009 crisis
right we never actually saw the high
levels of inflation or the second school
of thought
is will this money printing lead to high
levels of inflation and there are is
hundreds of billions of dollars if not
trillions of dollars being bet on that
question right now is this going to
continue in a deflationary environment
or will we see that hyper inflationary
environment they could be sequential
continue right now in deflationary and
then in the future get high inflation
it could be immediate but that is what
every single person is betting on right
now in the market they have some version
of that in their investments we think is
gonna happen Oh God
you don't want me to predict anything no
all right what other questions we got in
here
is it the jacket
let's see here
pomp is a communist okay maybe he would
make a great first man I think okay so
the stock market looks forward 12 to 24
months so things could be terrible now
in two years better this is dennis more
marta so there's an element of this that
people are speculating in the stock
market for the future performance I
would argue though that most of the
speculation going on in the stock market
is looking at the economic data and
saying is actually not as bad as we
thought it was going to be now this
brings up warren buffett yesterday i
listened to it was for our thing some of
it I had you know without headphones on
so Plano was listening as well and I was
shocked that Warren Buffett how bearish
he was now he wasn't explicitly bearish
he was saying the right things in the
sense of never bet against America and
all of these things but as we all know
don't listen to what they say just watch
what they do with their money his cash
positions Roe Wells cash position is
definitely increasing - he sold 100% of
his airline stake we'll talk about that
in a minute
but also he hasn't deployed the cash
right so in 2008 2009 when things got
really bad he stepped in and provided
capital to different businesses and that
was kind of the signal of okay there's
blood in the streets Warren Buffett made
a move right and then there was a
recovery now you didn't
perfect timing but but generally that
was a thought process but he's not so
when the market drew down 30% everyone
was sitting there and literally people
were tweeting and writing articles like
waiting on Omaha right waiting on Oracle
of Omaha what is he gonna do when is he
gonna move what business is he gonna go
pick to save all these different
speculation because this is this should
be his like Super Bowl right of course
but he didn't make a move and so
yesterday he was asked why did you not
make a move and he specifically said at
one point he goes because we didn't see
anything yet that is attractive in every
word the market sold off 30% but he's
sitting there saying it we haven't seen
anything attractive yet and so what I
read into that was he thinks this is
gonna get worse before it gets better
right and then on top of that heat many
many times
kept talking about we don't know how
long this can go on for right kind of
alluding to the uncertainty or the
unknowns and so I think a lot of people
after yesterday are sitting there saying
wait a second Warren Buffett didn't make
a move yet if Warren Buffett hasn't
decided to jump into the market this
actually may be a negative impact where
are we gonna see stocks sell-off on
Monday and all that comes and how
quickly is he known to move when
something like this happens so he's
famous for saying Ted I'm paraphrasing
but basically he knows within the first
five minutes of a call whether he's
gonna do the deal or not
multi-billion dollar deal he pretty much
knows pretty quickly if he's gonna do it
or not because again remember he's
sitting on about 130 billion dollars of
cash a hundred and thirty billion
dollars and so he can do almost any deal
right for the most part and when he's
sitting there and he's waiting and he
said that he has some people calling him
but he felt that those people were
looking for terms that he was unwilling
to do where the businesses didn't make
sense he was very kind of supportive of
the Federal Bank actions basically
saying they acted quickly they did the
thing that you would have to do in this
scenario and so that probably alleviated
some of the pressure for these
individual businesses so they don't need
to come to him but if he does believe
it's gonna get worse again he could say
all he wants never bet against America
never bet against America but ultimately
what he's doing by not participating in
America he's not betting against it but
what he's definitely not doing is he
wasn't deploying capital to show that he
has skinned the game that he thinks
their recoveries under way right if he
had instead said hey actually what I've
done is
I've taken 20 billion dollars and I put
it into the market yeah that would be
kind of a vote of confidence and he's
just because he doesn't think there's a
good opportunity yet now the other thing
is the airlines so he for years
literally decades has always said that
he's not gonna go to the airline's so at
one point there's even a quote I think
back in 2007 maybe he said this where he
said something about like if a
capitalist had been at Kitty Hawk when
they did the first flight a good
capitalist would have shot down the
plane meaning like we wouldn't have an
airline industry because it's bad
investments right and so he's been very
bearish on the airlines for a long time
in 2016 out of nowhere he kind of
surprised everyone and he took a stake
in the four largest US airlines those
airlines he owned between seven to ten
percent of each of them and then all of
a sudden earlier this year there was
rumblings that he was selling his
position and yesterday he confirmed that
he sought a hundred percent of that of
that business now he explicitly said
that he made a mistake rest was kind of
intellectually honest and that hey I
made this mistake but on top of that
what I found really interesting was not
like they saw the entire position but he
was congratulatory and supportive of the
current leadership teams basically
saying I wouldn't want to be these CEOs
because this is such an anomaly like how
do you actually handle this situation so
I think that we're just seeing that the
virus is very unexpected it's very
improbable that it was going to happen
and now companies had to deal with it
and somebody like Warren Buffett who
even though he has a long time horizon
is kind of throwing his hands up in
certain situations and saying this is
too uncertain this is too much of an
unknown I don't want to play this game
that's interesting because all these
people I mean you see the stock market
going up all these people are saying is
gonna be a v-shaped recovery now that I
know what a v-shaped recovery is so well
I mean what's the truth like how do we
know what's gonna happen we don't and
that's where people are making the bet
right in the sense of you have to take
aside do you think that you're betting
on a quick recovery a long-term recovery
and it's not so much like black and
white because also how long is your time
horizon right so let's say for example
the stock market sold off 30% if you're
a 20-year investor as long as you don't
think America is gonna go bankrupt you
don't think these corporations are going
to zero the 20-year investor means like
I have to
years before I want to yeah III
basically making these investments and
I'm not worried about having to sell my
positional operation yeah I have a
really long time horizon right and so
when I do that then I don't necessarily
worry so much about the day-to-day price
what are they saying
imma save today I'm gonna save today
don't worry plan has been on me about it
I think that's one piece of it the other
thing that was really interesting
yesterday from Warren Buffett is he was
asked you haven't beat the S&P 500 for a
number of years now right why should we
invest in Berkshire rather than invest
in the S&P and again Warren bump are the
reason why people like him as he's so
honest he was like I actually encourage
you to invest in the SMP 500 well it's
not weird because it's the truth right
people actually if you want returns it
would be easier to drive a consistent
return the S P rather than Berkshire
because Berkshire again has so much
money but it's harder to make a good
return on hundreds of billions of
dollars than it is if I think it's
raising something like it'd be easier to
run five million dollars right he could
double and triple five million dollars
but to do it with hundreds of billions
of dollars it's just much much harder
before we keep taking questions go like
this video I keep getting messages
saying tell people to like the video
subscribe to the channel
alright what's the next question you
have any so I saw one what's your view
on the having on the having o Bitcoin so
on the macro backdrop actually hold on I
want you to say what do you think it is
please heard me say this a million times
can you repeat the one what is Bitcoin I
forget bitcoin is a an asymmetric
non-correlated assets it's a
decentralized digital currency okay do
you know what the having is so they're
having so there's 21 million bitcoins
right now total total total ever and the
having is gonna cut the supply
see there's none coming in coming daily
supply the incoming daily supply will be
cut
half so the so the demand will explode
but the supply will shrink that's pretty
that's directionally pretty good yeah
pretty good so basically right now 1,800
Bitcoin per day are produced
it's very programmatics very transparent
in about nine days give or take there's
going to be a 50% reduction in that
daily incoming supply so go from 1,800
to 900 Bitcoin obviously if you
understand supply and demand economics
kind of economics 101 if supply gets cut
and demand remains constant or increases
there should be a material increase in
price and so I generally think that
there is a supply shot coming obviously
right there's going to be a reduction in
incoming daily supply 50% reduction but
I also think that there's a demand shock
underway right people are realizing that
there's the potential risk right not
guaranteed but potential risk that
inflation could occur and therefore
they're running for asset that has
inflation hedge like properties and
there's the accessibility question so if
I'm somewhere in the world all I need is
an internet connection to get access to
Bitcoin to get gold maybe a little bit
more difficult to get dollars maybe a
little bit more difficult I need a bank
account things like that and then also
what we're seeing on top of that is in
certain areas around the world take
Lebanon for example in Lebanon the
Lebanese pound we've seen lose over 50%
of its value
ready continues to fall and I want to
spend a second here because I think that
this really highlights the benefit of
bitcoins in Lebanon and plena her family
actually saw something similar to this
in Bulgaria back in the day but if you
think about what's going on in Lebanon
so you've got people who were protesting
they were you know kind of
anti-government protest then all of a
sudden the buyers are curse they say go
inside so everyone goes inside the
currency continues to fall in value and
that has to impact them in two ways one
all of a sudden my pound buys less goods
so that loaf of bread that was let's say
five pounds is now seven pounds 8 pounds
10 pounds so the food prices rise but
not because the food value is changing
it's because actually the currency is
being devalued right so I need more of
the currency to buy that so everything
around me is getting more expensive the
other thing it does is it makes my
savings or my
less valuable so if I had a hundred
pounds all of a sudden now that same
hundred pounds the number didn't change
but what I can buy actually changes and
so I'm actually not as rich as I used to
be and so what do people want to do they
want to get out of the currency so they
go to the bank and they say hey give me
my money back
but don't give it to me in this country
that's being devalued give it to me in
u.s. dollars or give it to me in the
Euro give it to me in some other
currency the bank's recently said we are
not going to give you any other currency
other than the Lebanese pound now on top
of that what they then said was you
can't take out more money than X and I
don't remember the exact amount but they
started to put capital controls in place
so you couldn't withdraw a lot of the
money and you couldn't withdraw it in
any other currency and so it locks
people into that currency and what
they're doing is when they go to sleep
they wake up the next day and literally
their wealth is evaporating and
everything around them is more expensive
so what that then means is they're
getting paid in their salary right or
their hourly wages and that is not
changing it's not like all of a sudden
that same pound that I used to get can
buy the same good so just keep paying me
the same I'm actually now making less
and less I mean you want tell a story
about your dad yeah basically this was
in the 90s in Bulgaria there was some
sort of there's a lot of inflation and
he was working for let's say $300 a
month and all of a sudden his salary
went down to like three dollars or
thirty cents or something ridiculous so
he stopped going to work well he's like
his salary didn't change right the value
of what vehicle the US dollar equivalent
went from you know a hundred dollars or
whatever was to very very little but
what I thought was interesting that he
said was you know it's kind of like
common sense if you're getting paid
thirty cents to go to work and do the
same job would you still do it probably
not but he said that a lot of people
silk have gone to work day after day and
working for nothing because they were
scared to lose their position well the
it's a social construct right in twofold
one you're being told that it's gonna
get fixed right so there's a belief that
hey a solution is coming so if some
people buy that narrative
and then the second is it is a
rebellious thing to stop going to work
right there there's a sense of your
neighbors are going to judge you right
what else am I gonna do or my families
cuz you quit your job why are you not
going to work right you you've abandoned
your work so there's that element to it
but in these situations people want to
get out so what that leads us to then is
an access problem they want dollars
dollars are right now valuable they're
stable comes with the full you know
faith in Credit of the United States all
of these benefits the problem is they're
hard to get so in Lebanon right now it's
hard to find and there's probably a
black market going on but it's dangerous
right how do you know that you're not
gonna show up to buy some dollars and
somebody doesn't literally shoot you or
stab you or rob you did you know do all
this stuff and then how do you determine
the value right the official exchange
rate is different than the unofficial or
black market exchange rate so that's
problem with dollops gold there's a
shortage of these of these precious
metals around the world and they're
actually trying to fly them to places
and help do that but with Bitcoin all
you need is an internet connection you
literally can get on the internet sign
up for an account in all of these
various platforms and you can buy
Bitcoin and hold on to it and you don't
have to worry about only finding it
somewhere locally around you you can
literally use the internet to get access
to a currency that then also can't be
seized right and so I think that slowly
but surely we will see country after
country after country go through similar
situations and we will see people start
to realize the value of a decentralized
digital currency I know you've said that
this can't happen in the US but why not
it's not that it can't happen I don't
believe it's gonna have this rate medium
term there's three things so one is that
there's a guy Brent Johnson Santiago
capital in San Francisco he's got this
year he calls it the dollar milkshake
there and the dollar milkshake Theory
basically says central banks around the
world are pumping all this liquidity
they're all printing money and they're
throwing it into the the global
financial system as they do that what
ends up happening is that all of that
liquidity is going to move and be sucked
up into one asset right that one asset
being the US dollars the US dollars
gonna continue to gain strength over
time because all-out liquidity flows to
the dollar so the whole idea is central
banks are making a milkshake
by putting liquidity in and the dollar
has a straw and it's sucking
so dollar milkshake theory now that
would put the US dollar continued to
actually strengthen and have a
deflationary environment so it sucks up
liquidity that the Federal Reserve puts
it the second thing is that we or one of
the most disciplined countries in the
world when it comes to monetary policy
where they say but the second but the
second thing is the u.s. is one of the
most disciplined countries right so if
you look at something like Venezuela for
example how do they get to the point
that they get to they became
undisciplined in their monetary policy
and so because of that lack of
discipline you get hyperinflation you
get all these negative effects that's
obviously in the United States were
pretty good about it and people have to
go back and understand in 2008 2009
there's a lot of these same concerns
people were worried about hyperinflation
they were oh my god we're printing
hundreds of billions of dollars
we never saw those high levels of
inflation because we were already in a
deflationary environment and was able to
suck up all that liquidity now on top of
that inflation hedge assets did very
well
so gold even though it went down 30% in
2008 over the summer drum liquidity
crisis it still ended up going up about
200% after that and hit an all-time high
so I think those types of assets will do
pretty well make sense huh all right
what else any other questions in here um
I was keeping an eye did you see any
good ones I saw some inappropriate ones
but hold on let's see
everyone loves Polina they love Oh
what's your favorite book what's your
favorite book I have four books that I
wanna recommend
okay you go recommend them Guns Germs
and Steel Jared Diamond Rich Dad Poor
Dad by Robert Kiyosaki yeah the richest
man in Babylon and thinking girl rich
Napoleon Hill those are the four books
if you read those four books you will be
ahead of the game when it comes to the
world and thinking are we talking like
inspirational books no what's your
favorite book oh I don't know I have a
what are some of the best books you've
read recently um
have read recently reading a lot about
okay um okay I'm just gonna recommend
one it's not my favorite but I think
it's good to read right now it's called
the geography of bliss what is that well
so it's um this reporter who was like
covering war zones and he got super
depressed so he decided to look at this
list of like the top ten happiest
countries in the world and he was like
what the hell makes them happy so he
went to them in here oh it's a really
humorous account of the way people act
in certain countries so he goes to like
Switzerland and Sweden and I think he
goes to one really sad country um
Moldova I think but anyway the way he
writes about it is really interesting
and right now I know a lot of people
can't travel but it's just a good way to
get your mind off of what's happening I
tell them what you told me today about
traveling and the whole idea of like
seeing other places not changing myself
oh yeah so the reason I like traveling
is because it lets you see new places
with fresh eyes like I was telling him
when I first moved to New York I
remember how I was like whoa everything
was new and cool and now I try to
recreate that feeling but I've gotten
used to New York so when you go to new
places it's kind of cool I agree I think
the exposure to other societies cultures
and economies it just gives you a much
better perspective when evaluating
various situations I read someone wrote
this I forget who I was a travel writer
but he said it rearranges your cultural
furniture so you kind of like you've
built something in your head this like
mental model of how the world works and
then you go to a place a different place
and it's just completely do you remember
we went to Bali last year and I thought
it was really cool now that I think
about it our guide told us that
basically in every community they all
live wherever you were born in whatever
house you kind of stay there your whole
life and let's say you get really rich
during your life you don't go move to a
rich neighborhood you stay in the same
neighborhood maybe you build a bigger
house but you're still there and it's
kind of like it's this idea that the
rich and the poor live in the same
places they
don't segregate kind of like we do here
I agree people want to know your
hometown Sofia Sofia Bulgaria all right
two other questions that are in the
comments let me do first the the digital
currency and this people are asking
about real estate as well on in terms of
digital currency so the questions
basically are about this idea if
nation-states come out with their own
digital currency so a digital dollar a
digital euro digital wan digital yen etc
what does that do to to Bitcoin I said a
number of times that I do not believe
that we are going to see a competition
between on that the technology layer so
it's not going to be a digital currency
versus a non digital currency I think
the kind of obvious conclusion is that
100 percent of currencies will be
digitized so we will have a digital
dollar digital euro Bitcoin you know
stable coins all stuff where the
competition is going to occur is at the
monetary policy layer so that every
currency will be digital and then you
have various monetary policies so if you
think about from a market perspective
accessibility goes to 100% anyone in the
world can now access any currency in the
world because of them all being digital
now you get full on competition at the
monetary policy level I personally
believe that people will choose to seek
out a non inflationary asset especially
one that is non sovereign and one that
is decentralized and so if you look at
this let's go through the game theory of
let's say at the country level right so
I'm a whole bunch of reasons why we
would do that I think we might have just
lost people for a second but we're good
and so people basically then would have
to use the dollar instead now what will
be available as we use a digital
currency I think that people are going
to enjoy and seek out the transparent
nature that Bitcoin provides because
they know that nobody is manipulating it
they know exactly what is happening and
so in those situations I think over time
will happen in the short term but over a
long period of time people will just
naturally opt for this transparent
decentralized thing that that can't be
manipulated
can I play devil's advocate for a second
of course you can do that in your in
your Canadian tuxedo go ahead
you guys I'm wearing a Nike shorts okay
if what you just said is true why
haven't we seen an explosion in the
price of Bitcoin during this time we
have big thick Bitcoin is up 25% so at
the beginning of the years up 25% over
the last year it's up over a hundred
percent hold on is up over a hundred
percent and bitcoins the best performing
asset over the last decade I get that
but it has not increased in a dramatic
way as you would expect in a time of
crisis like this there's two pieces to
this argument so one is you could make
the argument that it could being up 25
plus percent year-to-date is it's been
three and a half months right like it's
not like there's been a long period of
crisis three and a half months the
beginning of the year to now when kovat
really kind of started to when it hit so
being up 25 percent it's the best
performing asset done better than gold
better than stocks but in Treasuries
everything else is outperformed the
other argument would be that people like
wait is it there's trillions of dollars
being printed why is there not all
sudden explosion like it doubles or
triples in price right I think that's
what you're asking
that's just not what happens right and
what I mean by that is there's no asset
in the world where all of a sudden
everyone at the same exact time makes
the decision on the same day and moves
over and all shift their wealth into
something else even in these countries
like Lebanon etc we're talking about the
structural issues majority of the
population is still using that currency
it sucks because it lost value but there
even though their currency is is getting
hit even harder than people think the US
dollar could get hit people still don't
leave because one they're not paying
attention to they don't know how to do
it three they don't care like there's
all these issues to it so what I
actually believe in some happenings go
back to gold in 2008-2009 in the
liquidity trap or the liquidity crisis
over the summer of OE gold went down 30%
everyone wants dollars everyone sells
every asset in that liquidity crisis
Bitcoin wasn't safe from that went down
50% one day
gold went down 12% stocks went down 30%
everything got sold now what we will see
is kind of this March back into assets I
think over the next 18 months you're
gonna see Bitcoin make a material
movement in price some of that is
related to
having some of that is related to kind
of naturally people just discovering it
and understanding it and wanting it and
then a lot of it is related to the
Federal Reserve actions so it's kind of
like worse at the beginning of this and
you can't really evaluate the
performance of an asset in the first you
know couple of weeks of a crisis you
almost have to wait till you have the
hindsight bias and then you can say this
performed well this didn't perform well
right because the thing about three or
four weeks ago when stocks were down 30%
you could have been like oh my god
stocks are selling off it's crazy now
you're like wait a minute going down 10%
for the year right so like it's really
not that bad if you love this is a good
question
Pauline are you worried that pom has
over 50% of his net worth and crypto
what do you think so we always talk
about every time do you want deep wealth
tell them our strategy first
so I own no Bitcoin I wanted to one-time
but then I didn't I invested SNP well
played abate so our whole strategy is
there's two people here and if you think
about barbell I take like 99.9 percent
of the risk she takes near zero risk and
so we both have very very long time
horizons were relatively young and were
able to continue to allocate capital on
that long time horizon I have a
obviously a very material percentage of
my net worth in Bitcoin
I hold a decent amount of cash and then
I have real estate is kind of the third
biggest bucket and then on top of that I
have a number of kind of private company
investments that that are a high-risk
high-reward type stuff
polina on the other hand is basically
cash and SNP and the thought process is
if you look at the two of us can you
like ask are you are you alluding to me
calling out kevin O'Leary this is a
great video of kevin O'Leary being like
50% of your net worth in Bitcoin I
forbid it
what did he say well it's two different
seconds but yeah I'm one of the segments
I say he they asked me a bitcoins backed
by nothing
and even though I disagree with that I
said but neither is the US dollar and
how BIG's your cash position what are
you saying there uh let's go to
commercial and they just kind of way but
but I think that our whole thought
process here is we're actually very kind
of risk-averse in the sense of how we
look at you know kind of allocating
funds across the both of us
the second thing is from a Bitcoin
perspective it would be nice or it would
be kind of a cool gesture if Bitcoin
owned a Bitcoin maybe maybe we'll get it
be a quashed yeah just in the sense of
like our Bitcoin exposure across both of
us I'm taking that risk so there's
really no need for her to own one but at
the same time it will get you one so
that you can say you I don't want to say
do I want to say that I do you want do
like saying you don't own Bitcoin I
don't like I don't want people to say
like oh she's a crypto bro if I owned
one you know I would calm that and I
can't you can't literally look at like
the daily fluctuations I'll be like oh
so you'll be a degenerate on Twitter
with everyone in the comment section
alright the other thing is I saw a bunch
of questions in here about a real estate
so let me do two things let me first
kind of talk about how what we've done
in real estate
already and then I could talk about what
we're looking at now so currently the
pieces of real estate we own a little
bit of residential and also a little bit
of commercial the commercial real estate
is obviously commercial but it's
somewhere where we went in bought a
piece of property we had a business
already in mind that was going to go
ahead and take that property and they
locked into a long-term lease that's
going very well their business is still
doing very well we're not worried about
anything there in terms of their ability
to pay and so that the commercial side
looks great on the residential side
we've got a very small number of
residential pieces of property and those
are fully rented out 100% occupancy
everything there looks good its
remaining profitable and so we kind of
don't have any concerns now I am getting
very excited about the real estate
market I think that the the two big
things that we're going to see is one
we're gonna see a massive sell-off in
commercial real estate both here in New
York City and elsewhere the way people
work is just going to change
there will be somewhat of a shift to a
more remote work but on top of that I
think that you're starting to realize a
good business owners turn arose wait
maybe we don't need this much space
maybe we don't need this many employees
we're kind of getting the ability to
reset and I think that I'll have a
material impact on prices in the
commercial space so looking at that and
then on top of that too is people are
always going to need somewhere to live
and so on the residential side we're
taking a look at a number of pieces of
real estate not so much looking at
things that have been on the market
previously really looking for situations
where either one life events or driving
people to want to sell so there's some
what motivated sellers and really
looking for not not necessarily giving
away the property but definitely kind of
open to taking a little bit less capital
than they originally wanted because of
those life events and the second bucket
is there's definitely people who are
kind of caught in this liquidity crisis
they need liquidity and so trying to
find a balance between you don't want to
be the shark you don't want to go in and
kind of screw them over but at the same
time when the markets changed there's
kind of blood in the streets you want to
be able to to be there to act somebody
or a few people are asked about
residential real estate will there be a
sale I definitely think we're gonna see
three major trends or maybe they're not
major trends but three trends that are
gonna kind of play out over time so one
is that I think a lot of people are
gonna start to realize having a strong
balance sheet really matters they
probably have big mortgage payments and
kind of the financial position that
they're in right now strong balance
sheet meaning they have a lot of cash
meaning they have more assets and
liabilities they spend less than they
make they save they've got like their
financial shape that they're in a good
strong position go on and so what I
think you're gonna see is over time what
happened immediately but over time
you're gonna see people kind of downsize
their homes they're gonna realize maybe
I don't need this big mortgage payment
so that will happen over a period of
time the second thing you're gonna see
is there's a lot of people who can't
afford the mortgage right now right and
so you guys see foreclosures and kind of
everything that the washout of people
not being able to pay which is very
unfortunate and that's kind of why we
got to get people back to work in a safe
manner but but I definitely think you'll
see that the third thing that I think
you're gonna see here is you're gonna
see a migration where people are gonna
say look I live in New York City why do
I live in New York City when I can do a
lot of things digitally maybe I don't
need to pay so much money for an apart
I could go spend that exact same amount
of money living somewhere else and buy a
bigger property or a bigger a piece of
real estate and so those three things I
think are going to people tell you to
hit me hey Steve B I see you saying flip
crawlspace right now for no reason to
see what he does I appreciate it uh-huh
so I think that basically what ends up
happening is residential real estate is
going to look different and you're gonna
see two things is certain markets are
gonna get hit hard and actually going to
suffer certain workers are gonna become
hot and they're gonna benefit from this
what I'm specifically interested in is
looking at markets that I know so North
Carolina is a market that I know New
York City is a market that I know and
looking for kind of these you know very
special situations and the reason why I
say special situations is there's kind
of down the fairway deals right
basically if you screw it up you're
gonna make money but but they're not
necessarily Grand Slams right the piece
of commercial real estate that that
Jason Williams and I bought is is a
grand slam deal right we're gonna make a
decent return on that and it was fairly
simple as very obvious that we should do
that deal as soon as as soon as it was
presented to us and so I think that's
really what I'm looking for here is I'm
not gonna take a lot of swings but when
we do swing I think we're gonna look for
a couple of grand slams and really
that's either based on the price that
we're buying it at right kind of the the
return that you drive is based on the
price you buy or - is the type of real
estate that we buy so even if we pay
kind of a market price for it just
something that doesn't come up for a
trade very often is something we'll be
looking for as well so that's kind of
the thoughts on real estate if you got
real estate that you want to sell please
let me know I'll definitely take a look
at it but but we are definitely looking
for real estate what stops the
government from simply banning owning
trading and crypto currencies once they
feel they might pose a threat to their
own currency would that not essentially
end crypto I asked this question all the
time if one country bans it another
country will open it with wide open arms
because no one can stop it so it's not
like let's say for example you know go
back to the days of music if you guys
remember things like LimeWire Napster
etc it was supposed to be quote unquote
p2p right file-sharing but at the end of
the day there was a company that owned
it
somebody who was in charge of it Nikki
go arrest that person they could go shut
down that company put down the servers
whatever in this case even if they said
in the United States its banned firown'
from ownership you cannot own
cryptocurrency
then what would just happen is Russia
China India all these other places
around the world that here's our
opportunity here's how to get off the US
dollar the US has now banned this if we
go ahead and we embrace it and we do it
together then that will drive the
adoption and will move off the US dollar
system so I think that there's kind of
this game theory at play where unless
you had full global coordination among
all superpowers to ban ownership and
also to work to shut down all of the
miners I just don't see them being able
to do it because whoever acts first to
do that will end up being on the wrong
side of the trade because they're
adversaries in economic world will end
up embracing it and benefiting from them
having taken that action first um there
was a question here this one if the
point of Bitcoin is to be your own bank
doesn't block fine defeat the purpose by
giving a third party or a Bitcoin so
there's two things right so one
obviously is yes Bitcoin gives you the
ability to be your own bank by no means
do I think you know that prints
Floria block five myself any of the
other investors or any employees there
think that people should go put a
hundred percent of their Bitcoin into
block Phi or any other service right any
of these services at the same time you
know the way that I think about this is
actually a really important point so I
do not look at Bitcoin in US dollar
terms I couldn't tell you how much
Bitcoin I own a US dollar terms what I
do know is how many Bitcoin I am and
it's because I've switched my mindset to
a Bitcoin denominated world so planet
can tell you the story of literally when
we moved into our last apartment we
didn't have a couch for like two and a
half months because I was sitting there
and I was saying I'm not gonna spend X
Bitcoin to buy that couch
I was drinking wine on a yoga mat in the
middle of the I have atoned for my sins
I was wrong but at the time Bitcoin was
very very low and I was looking to
acquire more Bitcoin not spend it coin
and so the thought process is I just
nominate everything in Bitcoin and
not in US Dollars and so the same thing
with something like block 5 is I would
like to earn a return on some of my
wealth and obviously Bitcoin itself can
go up or down in price so this is some
price appreciation or depreciation there
but you can also earn interest and so
what I do is I take a very small percent
of my holdings and I put that in as a
user of block fight to earn on their
interest-bearing account now it's an
amount that one if I lost it all I'd be
comfortable with that - I've done my
research and I'm comfortable with the
risk that I'm taking at block 5 but on
top of that I also think that the amount
of interest that I'm earning is
commemorat with the risk that I'm taking
right and so right now that's SAT word
for those of you keeping track it and so
if you think of blockers those that
don't know you can go to block 5 comm
slash pop Bach five.com / pop - check it
out you can earn 6% interest or 6% APY
on your Bitcoin and you can earn up to
eight point six percent APY on
additional dollar so before we leave I
want to leave you guys with this a lot
of people ask me all the time what is
like one of the best trades or
investment ideas I have right now i will
caveat all of this with i'm an investor
a user and block phi is a sponsor of the
podcast so i'm highly highly bias here
but I tell this to all of our
institutions this is the conversation I
had behind closed doors if I was
somebody who had a amount of cash
sitting in the bank what I would do and
what I have done is I would take a
portion of that cash I would deposit it
into a digital dollar I would take that
digital dollar and I would put it into
the interest-bearing account on block
five and earn up to eight point six
percent ap lot now why would I do that
one is I'm not taking price risk right
it's back to one to one to the dollar so
when I put my US dollars in those
dollars go and sit at State Street in a
cash denominated account so State Street
has custody of my dollars I'm issued a G
USD or USD C right so let's say G USD so
Gemini issues me a digital dollar that's
tied one to one to the cash I then take
that digital dollar and I deposit it
into an interest-bearing account that
pays me eight point six percent a py so
I recently
and said well the stock market's
crashing I would be earning a guaranteed
8.6% a py at today's rates by simply
having cash sit in there and earn
interest it's a higher interest rate and
the reason what they're doing how we're
able to pay that is they're taking my
digital dollar and they're lending it
out right just like what I put dollars
in my bank account the bank takes those
dollars and lends them to other people
they earn let's say 2% they then pay me
literally five basis points 0.05 percent
right and they keep the difference what
blackfyres doing is I'm depositing
digital dollars they're taking my
digital dollars they're lending it out
at very high rates and then they're
getting paid that that high rate and
they're giving me eight point six
percent 8py on my money so it's a way to
earn very high degree of interest
without taking significantly more risk
than you're already taking in your bank
account now one of the differences is
that you don't have FDIC insurance on
the digital dollars right you do
statestreet obviously has insurance on
your cash but there's some risk good
what what there's it's not FDIC insured
so your cash the US dollars that you
deposit they go sit in the strict State
Street account that account has
insurance on it because as regular US
Dollars right just like when you have it
in your bank account under 250 K as you
as an FDIC insurance what Jim and I then
does with G USD is they give you a
digital dollar back in return that
digital dollar is backed one-to-one
right you can see an audit of your pay
they have my hundred dollars I have a
hundred G USD that G USD when I put it
into block-like does not have FDIC
insurance right so there's a there is
risk right that's why I said if you
would need to go do their own research
but again I don't go do this with all of
my cash but the reason why I here for
the risks but the reason why I believe
that this is interesting right and we
invested in the company and I'm a user
is because I believe if you if you size
the risk correctly in your portfolio
earning eight point six percent on cash
you can't do that anywhere else so for
example what we tell institutions is if
you're really kind of forward-thinking
take five percent of your cash position
go do this and even if you keep earning
you know fifty to a hundred basis points
in your money market account that five
percent can materially increase the
total return on your cash right so you
can basically
sighs it correctly where your downside
risk is you would lose 5% of everything
went wrong but you're getting 8.6
percent it moves your cash position so
if you guys want to learn more about
that go to block 5 comm slash pop is
that it's just a website where it has
all of the information they know that
I'll send people to that exact website
that they use for the podcast so go
check that out I don't wanna spend too
much time talking about that but that
that is one thing that I think is really
really important
and it's kind of one of my better ideas
in terms of that the second idea
obviously is I think Bitcoin is going to
be the best performing asset coming out
of this financial crisis and the third
thing that I'm doing personally is I am
looking at a lot of real estate I think
real estate will be quite attractive I
own no public equities Plano owns the
SMP but we don't speculate in the public
markets in terms of buying individual
stocks or really have an opinion about
individual price movements unless you
have some this is not advice but I'm
interested in your answer this is not
advice do not listen to what she says
she knows nothing I know everything I
know nothing either if you had to buy
only one stock right now in order for
ten your get in trouble narrow what just
just like what was the one stock then
you would go look at right that you
would say hey you know what I think that
this company's gonna do really well tell
you something like why coca-cola cuz
Warren Buffett drinks it and also I like
it and also um it's such a it's bad
logic no listen it's a company that has
stood the test of time not a good show
so like a Linde effective the longer say
know what that means the longer
something persists you know more likely
it is yeah people are commenting that
you're attractive I agree thank you guys
somebody said they would invest in my
smile I'd short that for sure alright so
yes we will continue to make videos we
really really appreciate everyone
watching before I forget go like this
video go share it leave a comment we'll
do our best to go answer as many
comments as possible but please like and
subscribe to the channel so we can keep
doing this and grow it put a ring on it
I already did
for those who don't know I think we
should since the beginning point is my
as my fiancee
so that's why she's here I hate the Red
Sox heavy into VIX right now you know
you're luring them to you got it you got
a like put space between your words I
can't can't keep up like them I'm just
saying how about I use exposure the
stock marketing crypto look you know it
they definitely have exposure to the
stock market ended crypto I don't know
if they're necessarily a great stock to
to vote or not we will not be
broadcasting our wedding that is not
going to happen
polina you are 90 percent of my
portfolio
please basically 100 percent of my
portfolio I'd give up every dollar that
that I have in order to keep her so
that's probably pretty good we do one of
these every day where I'm like funnier
because today I just didn't feel like
discussing your Bitcoin stuff but um we
do lunch money every day around noon
that's true on YouTube let's see what
else literally I can't keep up all these
comments you guys are putting in here
Flynn is very attractive as she's
ignoring me and my questions to watch
Tom Araya I just responded no shoutouts
let's see
what's my Sega's biggest holding after
Bitcoin cash I yeah
or I guess real estate technically on a
value basis but but in terms of liquid
investment funny how people use all
these big words I have a cash position
why don't you just say I hold cash like
I have cash why is its have to be a
position well because I think of as it's
like a pie chart and what percentage of
it is in cash versus Bitcoin versus
something else okay in my wallet I got
cash do you guys see I have to deal with
all right what else here aetherium okay
let me touch on a theorem and then we're
gonna we're gonna go that you can ask a
couple more fantasies one that we can we
can so fast I know so on aetherium look
we should encourage experimentation we
should encourage innovation I think that
there are certain aspects of what people
are doing they're like decentralized
finance that will be interesting I
ultimately believe though that you need
sound money to make any of it work
I do not believe that ether is sound
money I do not believe that
eath will serve as money over any
significant period of time
we haven't made investments right so
don't listen to what I say just watch
what we're doing with our capital at
Morgan Creek Digital we have made
investments in companies that are
building on a theorem that are using the
various aspects of aetherium so
obviously we think there's value there
but when it comes to kind of ether
specifically as money I just don't see
it I think that it's the narrative has
shifted quite a bit over time and so you
know we'll see what happens there but
but obviously the use of smart contracts
is interesting defy I think is very
interesting the question just becomes
can you build it without the soundwave
principles if I decentralized finance
yes got a genius on my hands all right
what else anything else you know we
should do one of these where we asked
some people questions and they answer no
I don't want to that scares the [ __ ] out
of me
all right guys listen I appreciate you
guys watching this please like this
video make sure you're subscribed to the
channel if you want to share the URL
that'd be fantastic if you leave a
comment Lin and I whether it's healthy
or not we read every single comment and
it's not healthy and we try to respond
to almost every single one if you're an
[ __ ] in the comments what you want to
know one time what one time somebody
said something really mean and plain
cried we're not gonna say what it was
we're not gonna say what it was but
somebody says something very mean
inflated cried it was one of the first
time she ever went into the internet
section or the comment section of the
Internet and I had to explain to her
that you can't take it seriously got
alright guys we appreciate you guys
tuning in for last hour so and we will
see you guys tomorrow for less money at
noon bye